right at the beginning of this I said to
you integrals integration has to do with
area but it's it's a different kind of
area it's like area but not its area but
not your grandma's area okay we have to
treat it a little more carefully there
were nuances you have to watch out for
so the key is in how the question is
phrased and let me give you two County
examples okay let's come back to this
guy over here right now it's part of a
straight line and if you saw this
function and they said okay let's let's
call it y equals 2x let's just say
that's what it is that's what it looks
like and let's call this value negative
one to zero okay now if I asked you if a
question posed to you in the HSC
what is the shaded area just mind the
way the question has been asked what is
the shaded area it's not a trick
question have they said anything about
integrals no they have not have they
said anything about signed areas no they
have not
the question is just what's the area how
big is that thing
okay in which case if you see it
underneath the axis but they don't say
in for your integrals that I don't think
chaining him outside they're just saying
how big is it right so you need to call
that a positive area because just like
lengths like in Pythagoras you work out
a hypotenuse you used to disregarding
the negative because lengths are
positive
well areas in themselves also positive
okay so if the question said what's the
area give like work out the triangle and
then just say I don't know like five
square units full-stop no negatives okay
if on the other hand and this is the
exact reverse kind of question okay they
will pose you actual questions like this
you see them in your textbook when I
give you the HSC practice questions on
this topic you'll see them as well they
will say for something like this I'm
just going to get rid of my answer for a
second they will say evaluate the
integral of f of X evaluate the integral
from 0 to 6 ok so this is a very
different kind of question right it's
closely related areas are still involved
but because it says work out an integral
work out an integral now you have to pay
attention to where the areas are does
that make sense I have to pay attention
to position so how would I actually do
this well let's work out the areas above
the x-axis first tell me what kind of
shape is there I know it's a bad diagram
but just guess looks like a rectangle
right to work out the area of a
rectangle you just need width and height
so therefore you would say okay well
that's gonna be 2 times 3 sorry I have a
bad vertical scale you get the idea okay
that's above the axis then you've got
this guy which is a semicircle right
that Center there would be 4 which makes
its radius 1/2 so because it's a
semicircle I would say 1/2 PI R squared
that's the area so this angle but of
course look at where the semicircle is
it is beneath the x-axis does that make
sense so because the question has said
to you tell me what the integral is now
you pay attention to your position
whereas over here when they said tell me
what the area is it's just a measurement
question nothing to nothing to do with
calculus and all that fancy stuff ok so
then you would say that's 6 take away 2
pi that's squared that's going to be
negative 0.28 something something
something which is negative because that
semicircle ends up being bigger than
that rectangle ok does that make sense
so you have to pay attention to the
wording of the question quite carefully
and you will get more used to that
I don't worry about like oh man I need
to memorize this right now as you do
more questions you will get the practice
and you'll get a sense for it but I'm
just flagging it right now pay attention
to the way it's worded look at the
diagram and answer accordingly ok